aaron
is with us in marion illinois starting
off this hour hi
erin how are you good how are you guys
better than we deserve what's up sure
so my wife and i are in baby step two
and we have a
long way to go um and one of the things
we're trying to do is get rid of
the car that we go on um and we're
having trouble selling it
and so one of the ideas we've been
kicking around is because we're
a little upside down on it is to move
out in front and kind of pay
extra on to it to kind of knock down the
loan we don't
end up owing you know extra when the
bank
when we sell it um so we just thought
about that idea and just
advice on that if that makes sense
yeah i'm with you um how much debt are
you currently in all together right now
erin
uh right now we're at 191 000.
most of it's year long yeah i was about
to say that has to be student loans
who's the doctor or lawyer uh i'm an
accountant
and it just that number just keeps going
up doesn't it
wow so how much how much 191 or student
loans
uh about 100 about a hundred what do you
owe on the car
uh about 16 and it's
worth probably between
14 and 16. we've had it on we've been
trying to sell it for about a month
and have we haven't had anyone even what
kind of car is it
have you got have you got it listed at
the market value or what you owe
we i put it at the it's at the high end
of the keller blue book and so it's
which was this is 16. and so i mean it's
a little high
um pretty
i don't remember i have to look again
somewhere okay
yeah what's y'all's annual income right
now
uh well we have four kids my wife danced
at home and
uh we have about a hundred years
here okay all right so um
have you tried to borrow the difference
if you if you needed to borrow the three
thousand dollars to get out of the car
could you
um probably yeah you didn't want to
but i would rather you have three
thousand dollars in debt than sixteen
thousand dollars in debt
when you sell this car what are you
gonna drive
well uh we were gonna pile up some cash
as soon as we sold it and then try to go
buy a cheap van
this is basically the car that my wife
drives with all the kids
we have another car that's paid off for
about probably three or four
about 10 years it's just when you drive
to work yeah
okay so either plan would be fine yeah
to pay it down
and get rid of it or to take out a three
thousand dollar personal loan because
you reduced your debt
from 16 to three okay
you're still reducing the debt and you
can still pay off the three in your that
snowball
and it'll still be in your dead snowball
one of the quicker ones you get to
yeah yeah
okay yeah so either way it'll work but
yeah you're right to uh
the car is not your problem but you need
the traction because you're in such a
deep hole
right that you need to get you're doing
everything right to
get there and i appreciate you being
willing to sacrifice to cause it all to
happen
hey thanks for the call